so obviously like so many people i'm so
excited that bayside is back but first i
have to ask
how much fun have you been having
bantering back and forth with mario
lopez again
i mean it's like it's like breathing
it's so natural for us we
are like siblings we i laugh
so hard with him i mean we have the best
time we have the best best time
and we also have a similar work ethic so
what's great about it is you know when
we come in
and we're coming to rehearse and we run
our lines like what's so refreshing and
so comforting is
we don't even have to explain to the
other how we work
we just kind of picked up where we left
off to be honest it's been so many years
since we've acted together
i've been a guest on his show from time
to time but to
to just be in a scene and drop into
those roles again it was
so uh amazingly organic you know
it's it's a full circle moment for sure
that is very special
um you know bayside has changed a lot
since the 90s so what would you say
is better about it now and what are some
of the things you miss
um well great question i
well it's a unique thing to be
reflecting
on the question you just asked me
because i was a kid
when i the first go-around right yeah
now
in in my own growth as a woman
and then revisiting the place that is
such a big part of my childhood
it it's hard to kind of you know to to
separate you know what point of life i
was at when i last was there
right so compared to now um
but but you want to know like
what about the old one that i missed did
you say
yeah like what what what are you excited
for you know fans who grew up with this
show in the 90s what are you excited for
them to see with this new series
well here here's the truth is the new
one is
such a perfect mix that celebrates
so much about the old one so i don't
miss anything about the old one except
for if you were to say how would you
feel to be
15 again but i love being a woman i love
being a mommy to my son sky and married
to my greg so
i'll take that any day but the the
beautiful thing about
doing the show now especially with tracy
wigfield at the helm who did 30 rock
and the in the mindy project she
made sure as did we as producers to
really embed all the things that people
loved about it relationships connection
friendships the joy the hijinks and
and then even literally lots of easter
eggs that people are going to love to
see
who who loved it and cherished it and it
meant so much to as
as a kid in their own life but what's
really great though
to to get back to your initial question
too that our show
reflects the diversity in our world
and this is something that i'm very
proud of
and honored to you know help bring a
show like this
into the world and reflect the youth
culture of
of our real world um so our actors are
amazing
there's so much talent here i was a part
of the casting process from day one
and everyone they're such gems everyone
brings so much to their roles
i think people are going to really fall
in love with them and
and then they're going to get to revisit
with us whether they grew up with us
when they were kids or
because the show is so
multi-generational and has hit so many
generations through the years whether it
be before they went to school and while
they're eating their cereal to
coming home from school and were their
friends waiting there for them on tv
it has meant so much to people and
that's not lost on us we're grateful for
that
really quickly do you miss the 90s
fashion i do not
well i i don't okay i don't miss
i like certain things about 90s fashion
but i do not miss
jessie's wardrobe how's that perfect
the cavalry cheese i do not miss like
headbands on my forehead buddy bands i
don't miss any of that
but um although they might make a
reappearance here i just want you to
know too that i
am my dad's side of the family is
canadian and i love canada
so this is i love being able to talk to
you in a place that is one of my
favorite places in the world
oh i love that well thanks so much for
sharing that and thank you so much for
your time
i love this show i grew up um like
loving smarties and macintosh toffee
okay you're one of us yeah you know how
to smack it on the concrete and break it
in little pieces i know those tricks
you work for it yeah thanks so much